gracias por acompañarnos entradas 24 y
cuéntanos cuál o cuáles son las causas
de esta demora en los resultados
pero díaz guían a la causa esta demora
se debe a que terminado el conteo rápido
se han deducido nulidades sobre las
votaciones y se ha alegado que pueden
existir fraude en mesa ahora se dicen
irregularidades la mayor parte de éstas
han sido reducidas por la candidata
keiko fujimori
bueno pero además con el 100% las actas
electorales procesadas pero el 99 900 35
por ciento de las actas contabilizadas
es decir que falta un 0.65 00 65% por
escrutar pero castillo es el candidato
con más votos en las elecciones
presidenciales puede revertir este
resultado con las actas que faltan por
contabilizar en realidad lo que falta es
absolver las nulidades ya las actas de
todo el territorio nacional y de la
circunscripción de peruanos en el
exterior han sido contabilizadas lo que
ocurre es que se está señalando que
podrían haber existido suplantaciones o
errores en las mesas o llenados del voto
en blanco temas que no han podido
dilucidar se por la ausencia de
personeros de los partidos en todas las
mesas
entonces la candidata fujimori anunció
que habían como unas 800 actas
que serían impugnadas solicitando que el
jurado nacional de elecciones nos revise
ahora mismo ese trámite tiene dos
instancias y es la primera instancia la
que está recibiendo ese tema de manera
que la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales ha concluido con el cómputo
pero faltan la absolución de estas
nulidad es bueno también cuéntanos desde
su perspectiva qué significa para el
perú el hecho de que pueda ganar pedro
castillo y también que implicaría si
gana keiko fujimori
en cualquier caso envían a lo que
tenemos es un presidente o presidenta
sin mayoría en el congreso con el
congreso más fragmentado que surja de
una elección y hay además un congreso
que es muy calentado como son las
posiciones ideológicas de los candidatos
que tenemos en el camino la idea es
el principal consulado de perú y yo es
convocar a una asamblea constituyente
mientras que keiko fujimori plateas en
unas pequeñas reformas en términos
económicos se nombra una posición muy
estatista e intervencionista se ha
planteado la necesidad de cambiar la
economía social de mercado por una
economía popular con mercados y
controlar importaciones desde el lado de
castillo y más bien desde el lado de la
candidata fujimori mantener el tema
económico tal como está pero se ha
señalado la necesidad de dar al acuerdo
social de repartir el canon para así
tratar de arreglar las brechas sociales
y económicas que separan al territorio
del país y que se ha notado
especialmente en esta elección
bueno y finalmente cuéntenos cómo se
explica que en medio de un proceso
electoral pidan de nuevo la prisión
preventiva para keiko fujimori
ese es una situación un poco
inexplicable porque evidentemente acá
hay se siente incertidumbre en el país
con los electorales el fiscal ha
considerado que el asesor que aparece en
pantalla
es testigo en el proceso y al habérsele
visto juntos
la verdad es que esto en su opinión
estaría transgrediendo los principios
por los cuales de fujimori que se
encuentra en libertad
lo cierto el caso que nos encontramos en
una investigación fiscal no en un juicio
si las dos en este momento puedes estar
en mi puesta fundamentalmente en el
proyecto electoral el juicio continúa
como también a lo que había noticias del
juicio de vladimir cerrón es el
presidente del partido